is there anyone here tonight who's
actually died
and would like to talk about it
for real
where are you do you hear that thing did
you hear that go off it's like an angel
right there going don't say too much
mother
where are you what's your name
oh Manny okay Manny what happened to you
so Fentanyl
oxycodone and what
Xanax and it killed you yeah who was
there to [__] stick you Pulp Fiction
your ass who did that
you were gone bro yeah
yeah they brought you back
how long were you dead
do you celebrate that as a as a death
day a birthday like a second birthday
okay that's when you've been off drugs
thank you
listen
is that the is that the day you died
this is what I love about ads
that was the question I was getting at
that wasn't what [__] did it
okay that well he was probably like I
want two more bags of that [__]
and mom stay right here while I do that
[__] okay how long did you continue
using drugs after you [__] died
wow he's like well off and on uh
how long
four times
so in that eight-month span we got a
four stint four month four time excuse
me sit in rehab and one death
and you and then you got clean
after I got out of Scientology rehab
yeah what in the [__] oh we did
did you just hear that left turn we hit
listen that's where drugs will take you
right to Scientology
man I'm glad I asked this question
listen y'all I was disappointed in the
last crowd because when I put this tour
together and I looked at the map I was
like if anybody's died it's in Tampa
it's in Tampa I had my thumbpin in Tampa
for this where we go to clean up
great n a all right
now after n a
when do we hit Scientology
so your death was intentional and
Scientology was the accident
that were you saying to me because
statistically old paper that adds up it
does how do you end up in Scientology
thank you
we do have a show to get to appreciate
you man are you professional bro
I mean you died you know what it is you
know what time is all about let's just
truncate this [__] you know you know how
you know how important time is man
Boomer and didn't quite understand the
statistics
she just sent me them
listen
I can't be mad at your mom Manny because
I'm gonna be honest with you I don't
understand the statistics you just shot
at me either bro
I'll say sign your ass up where's L Ron
Hubbard get him the [__] out of here get
them on the spaceship and get his ass up
out of here
hahaha
oh God this is why I asked the question
I'm gonna stop bitching about my ass
lungs this mother died and that needle
shoved in them and then went in space
God damn
yeah thank you for thank you for making
me happy Manny I'm glad you're alive
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody down here in Tampa getting
game day ready for the live and Alive
Tour all tickets are available at
ryansickler.com about to tear up Tampa
get the tickets Let's Go Go books
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
funny show Ryan was absolutely
hysterical and he's just so authentic
love the show Ryan it was fantastic love
the podcast love the Honeydew podcast so
good to see you live but I know I gotta
sign up for the patreon you sign up for
a year you get over a month free